Welcome to You, Our Listener.
It's a real pleasure to sit down and invite you into a conversation that challenges some of our most deeply held assumptions about authority.
Absolutely.
And the text guiding us is this remarkable historical and theological treatise.
It's called Establishing imamate by the author Le Saburi.
He traces the imam across every prophet, then weighs the first caliphs against him.
The earth is never left without a guide, and that guide comes by designation, never by election.
And that is really the definitive spine of the author's argument.
To understand how he arrives at this, we have to recognize the specific lens through which he's reading sacred history.
We're exploring the classical Ismaili reading of these texts today.
Yeah, and that framework is key because it doesn't view the history of religion as just a museum of isolated, disconnected events.
Exactly.
It treats the long story of the prophets as a deliberate repeating template.
So history is an active, ongoing instruction manual showing us precisely how leadership is meant to function in our own time.
That perspective is absolutely vital.
I mean, if we treat the past merely as the past, we completely miss the architecture the author is revealing.
He operates from the premise that the creator is consistent.
The method of guidance provided to creation isn't arbitrary.
No, not at all.
And it doesn't change based on the era.
So by examining the very first moments of this architecture, we uncover the unbending rules
for every generation that follows.
Which brings us to the author's starting point, and it's entirely counterintuitive.
Before human beings even existed, before there was a single person on earth who could possibly need guidance, the earth was inhabited by angels.
Now, we typically think of a guide as a remedy for human frailty.
We need guidance because we are flawed, because we fail, because we fall into conflict.
Of course.
But the author begins his argument in a world entirely populated by beings who never sin.
and into this flawless, perfectly obedient environment, God announces that he is placing a vice gear hunt on earth, a deputy, a representative.
The author deliberately starts here to dismantle our most prophetic assumption.
He takes the idea that pure creatures have no need of a guide and completely inverts it.
If guidance were simply a concession to human weakness, there would be 0 justification for establishing a vice subverence over sinless angels.
So by declaring this designated authority over an impeccable creation,
The author is arguing that the need for a guide is woven into the very fabric of existence.
Precisely.
It is not an emergency measure.
It's the foundational principle established before humanity even drew a breath.
And the angels react to this announcement exactly the way a logical, merit-driven assembly would.
God announces this deputy and the angels question it based on merit.
They raise a very rational objection based entirely on observable facts.
Yeah, they point out that humans will corrupt the earth and shed blood.
The angels, conversely, glorify God's praise and declare His holiness flawlessly.
They look at their own impeccable record of worship and compare it to the anticipated violence of this new creature.
They're looking at the visible evidence, their own unbroken obedience versus the inevitable flaws of humanity.
And from that evidence, they draw the conclusion that they are the fitter custodians of the earth.
They don't seek power out of malice.
They don't shed blood.
They embody perfect piety.
But I want to push back on the author's framing here, to steel man the case for an elected body.
If we're choosing a leader, wouldn't sinless angels be the perfect, flawless electorate?
I mean, they have no jealousy, no greed, no desire for domination.
Why not let them choose?
That is the exact trap the author sets for the reader, and he resolves it by pointing to God's response.
Because God does not debate the angel's facts, he doesn't deny that humanity will shed blood or cause corruption.
Right, he issues a direct veto instead.
Exactly, with a single statement from the text, he says, I know what you do not know.
He overrules their objection entirely.
And the profoundly important detail here is that God corrects their underlying assumption about what qualifies someone to identify a guide.
The angels believed that their visible merit, their perfect worship and sinlessness, gave them the capacity to judge who should lead.
Yes, but God's veto establishes that the grounds for this appointment are invisible to creatures.
So the angels are looking at a visible ledger of behavior, but God is saying the role requires a fitness that cannot be seen by anyone but him.
The knowledge required to select the guide is entirely exclusive to the creator.
Precisely.
And this sets the stakes for the author's total rejection of an elected authority.
Consider the magnitude of this precedent.
If the single most qualified, impeccable electorate in the history of creation was explicitly denied the right to choose their leader, what excuse could a flawed, quarreling human assembly ever have for demanding an election?
If beings totally free from corruption and bias lacked the necessary knowledge to make the choice, a human assembly lacks it infinitely more.
The choice belongs to God because the fitness required for the role is fundamentally hidden from us.
So the author uses this event to establish a permanent rule.
The very first time creatures attempted to weigh candidates and render a judgment about leadership, they were corrected.
And that correction was recorded for all time.
He uses the absolute highest standard of the angels to dismantle the notion that any human community can gather and correctly identify the guide.
The dynamic we see with the angels isn't just an isolated incident, is it?
Not at all.
The author insists this is a recurring template.
The attempt to substitute creaturely judgment for divine designation is a pattern that will repeat itself throughout sacred history.
Let's trace that pattern forward to the next major crisis then.
We move to Noah.
The flood is imminent
and Noah is commanded to build the ark.
But the author introduces a critical detail regarding succession here.
Noah doesn't leave his community to figure out leadership on their own.
He appoints his son, Shem, by NAHSS.
That specific act is the technical center of the author's claim.
It is a clear verbal designation.
It's an explicit naming and transferring of authority from the outgoing guide to the incoming one.
It leaves absolutely no room for ambiguity.
It removes any opportunity for the community to convene a council or debate the merits of candidates.
The succession is stated plainly and publicly by the authority of the previous guide.
Exactly.
And it also pairs this verbal designation with the strictly defined physical image.
He argues that Noah's Ark was the I man.
The vessel itself serves as the living guide.
It's the ultimate image of salvation within this framework.
The ark isn't just a wooden structure.
It is the physical and spiritual vessel of rescue.
To survive the flood, you had to physically board that specific designated vessel.
Just admiring the ark from afar offered no protection.
None.
Building your own boat based on your own ingenuity offered no protection either.
You had to submit and attack yourself to the single guide that was plainly named.
The psychology of the people who drowned is really devastating.
I mean, they didn't perish out of ignorance.
They drowned in full view of the one named vessel.
They heard the warning clearly and they saw the ship being built.
Yet they were utterly confident that the solid ground beneath their feet would save them.
They trusted their own judgment, their own mountains over the designated guide.
They preferred their own choosing.
That is the recurring tragedy the author wants to emphasize.
A guide is offered explicitly, but the people feel secure in an alternative they have chosen for themselves.
To insist on trusting your own ground when a vessel of rescue has already been named for you is an act of profound self-destruction.
The solid ground they relied upon was the exact thing the floodwaters consumed.
Which brings us to a massive pivot in the text.
The author moves from these historical narratives of flood and rescue directly into the daily lived reality of a believer.
He argues that this unbroken line of guidance is not just a historical fact, it is coded into our daily worship.
He points specifically to the direction of prayer.
The author leads the physical world, and particularly physical acts of worship, as a system of deliberate symbols.
Visible actions are designed to point us toward invisible realities.
The direction of prayer, the orientation of the entire community is an instruction.
He argues that each prophet's chosen direction tells the community precisely where to look for the living guide of their age.
I don't buy that yet a change of prayer direction is geography, not a message about succession.
If we view prayer merely as a disconnected physical ritual, it certainly looks like geography.
But the author insists that a prophet's public acts are deliberate teaching instruments.
A communal gesture repeated constantly for generations is a bodily orientation meant to instill a spiritual truth.
So how does he decode this?
Let's take Moses.
He had no direct offspring for the I am mate to pass through.
His physical lineage wouldn't carry the office.
Therefore, he directed his people to face Jerusalem.
Oh, okay.
The author interprets this geographic choice as an instruction.
Since the office cannot run through his children, orient yourselves toward whoever among you carries the sanctified spirit.
The physical direction points toward a spiritual endowment.
So Moses detaches the direction from his physical family and attaches it to a quality, using Jerusalem as the physical anchor.
And then we see a distinct shift with Jesus.
Jesus also had no family or children to carry imamate.
The author notes that Jesus instructed his followers to face the east.
Yes, and the east is universally recognized as the place where light rises.
The instruction is to turn toward the dawning radiance of the living guide.
So the geography of the east is secondary.
Completely secondary.
The primary symbol is the rising light.
The community is being told to orient themselves toward whoever radiates the light of guidance wherever that light may dawn.
This leads us back to Abraham.
The author points out that Abraham honored the fire as a symbol.
We have to understand this within the specific framework the author provides.
it directly to a beautiful Quranic image.
He introduces the concept of the enor, al-may-amah.
The light of the imit.
Yes, this refers to the lamp in the niche.
The guide carries a light that God himself kindles, and this light steers the people through darkness.
When Abraham honors the fire, he is symbolically venerating that internal divine light carried by the guide.
So the fire is a physical stand-in for the lamp of guidance.
Furthermore, Abraham built the Kaaba.
By establishing this physical structure, he placed the center of veneration squarely within his own lineage.
He was commanding the future to look to his descendants to find that light.
Exactly.
He anchored the search for guidance in his own family line, which brings us to the profound resolution orchestrated by the Prophet, peace and blessings of Allah be upon him and his family.
Initially, the community faced Jerusalem, but the Prophet then turned the direction of prayer decisively back to the Kaaba.
It's a homecoming.
By turning the community back to the house built by Abraham and Ishmael, the prophet is gathering up the history that preceded him.
He points the community definitively to Abraham's line through Ishmael, directing their attention to his own children who descend from that exact line.
To anticipate the counter-argument, some might say, if God's way never changes,
How do you explain the shifting of the prayer direction from Jerusalem to the Kaaba, or the changing rules of fasting?
Yeah, that's a fair question.
The author answers this by pointing to the text, which speaks of God's established way, the Sunnah.
The author makes a crucial distinction here.
The established way that never changes is not the specific ritual practice.
Rituals are variables that adapt to the era.
So what is the constant?
The constant unchanging sunna across every single cycle of history is the presence of the designated guide.
The earth always has a designated authority.
To accept that this was true for Adam, Noah, Abraham, and Moses, but to deny it in the final cycle of the prophet is a massive contradiction.
You cannot apply an ironclad rule to the entirety of sacred history and then demand the opposite rule for the single case standing right in front of you.
The earth is never left without a guide and that guide comes by designation, never by election.
The author has meticulously built this historical precedent.
We've moved from the angels to the flood, through the prophets, seeing that the guide is always present and always designated.
Now we arrive at the stakes, we transition to the historical succession following the prophet.
This is where theology hits the messy reality of human events.
Yes, it is.
But I have to challenge the motive here.
Isn't this just replacing one power grab with a sacralized one?
We are looking at a chaotic historical transition, and it seems the author is simply applying a divine gloss
to elevate his preferred candidate.
That is the most common critique of any historical polemic.
The author counters this suspicion by refusing to rely on insults or manufactured scandals.
He employs an objective measuring rod derived directly from the text.
Okay, how does he do that?
He takes 3 specific virtues that God himself named in the Quran as marks of rank, knowledge, holy struggle, and piety.
He takes these three divinely certified virtues and measures the historical figures against them.
Crucially, he uses their own accepted historical records to conduct this measurement.
Let's examine the virtue of holy struggle, which elevates those who strive over those who sit back.
The author anchors this analysis in a specific event, the Battle of Hunain.
Hunain serves as the absolute crucible for this virtue.
The author details the historical reality of this battle.
The prophet gave an explicit direct command to his men to hold a mountain pass.
It wasn't a suggestion.
It was a military and spiritual directive.
The historical record, which all sides acknowledge, shows that Umar abandoned his position.
When the battle grew chaotic and the ground seemed to give way, he fled.
In a moment of crisis, he substituted his own judgment for the direct command of the prophet.
In stark contrast, the commander of the faithful, peace be upon him, held the field.
He obeyed the explicit command perfectly, remaining steadfast even as others retreated.
The author uses this not merely as a record of military bravery, but as a theological test of the precise quality required of a guide.
The chaos at Hunain is a microcosm of the entire conflict over succession.
True authority is not proven by standing near the leader in moments of peace.
No, it's proven under pressure.
Exactly.
It's proven by absolute unyielding fidelity to the leader.
command when the situation is terrifying, when everyone else is fleeing, and when it seems logical to retreat.
The first imam demonstrated the constancy required to hold his assigned post.
And the man later elevated to power failed that exact test.
The verdict on holy struggle is written by their own actions.
The author then moves to the virtues of knowledge and piety.
linking them inextricably.
He details how the father of imams defined the hierarchy of these virtues, arguing that true piety is impossible without profound knowledge.
The author quotes the first imam explaining this hierarchy beautifully.
Knowledge is superior to wealth because knowledge actively guards you, whereas you must expend effort to guard your wealth.
Yeah, wealth diminishes when you spend it, but knowledge actually multiplies when it is shared.
Exactly.
And the profound point regarding piety is that piety fundamentally consists of knowing what is lawful
and unlawful.
You cannot be scrupulously pious in your actions if you lack the knowledge of the law.
So piety is simply applied knowledge.
Therefore, the individual possessing the most complete knowledge must inherently be the most capable of true piety.
The author argues that all three virtues, holy struggle, knowledge, and piety, converge at their absolute summit in one person, the commander of the faithful.
These virtues don't point to a committee or an electorate.
They point to a single, specific individual.
And the community was not left to deduce this on their own.
The designation was spoken aloud.
It occurred in a place called Ghadir Qom.
Returning from his farewell pilgrimage, the Prophet physically halted the entire caravan.
He gathered the assembly together.
He took the first imam by the hand and publicly established his authority.
He performed the exact same act that Noah performed for Sham.
It was a clear verbal designation, eliminating any need or justification for the community to convene and hold a vote.
The naming was explicit and it was done in the open light of day.
This is where the author's method becomes truly devastating.
He turns to the historical record of the men who actually assumed power, analyzing the words they spoke from the pulpit.
According to the transmitted accounts, Abu Bakr stood before the community and confessed, I am not the best among you.
The author treats this pulpit confession as an inescapable logical dilemma.
If we analyze it with cold precision, there are only two possibilities.
The first possibility is that Abu Bakr was telling the truth.
If he was truthful in stating he was not the best, then his later partisans are lying when they claim he was the most excellent member of the community.
They are directly contradicting the man they revere.
Okay, I see the trap there.
Either he was telling the truth, which means his partisans are lying when they claim he is the best,
Or he was lying from the pulpit, and a proven liar cannot possibly be the guide.
Exactly.
There is no third option that preserves the claim of his superiority.
Some might try to defend this by claiming it was merely the modest self-deprecation of a humble leader, but the author completely rejects this defense by contrasting it with the behavior of true guides.
How so?
Well, the prophet openly stated his rank as the master of the children of Adam without any false modesty.
The commander of the faithful spoke openly of the torrent of knowledge pouring down from him.
I see.
A rightful designated leader states his rank plainly because it's the objective truth.
A public declaration of inferiority is not hidden modesty.
It's an accurate admission of a real absence of designation.
A man who has been designated knows his rank and does not disown it.
The author then drives the final nail into the argument for an election by using Umar's own words against the process.
Umar publicly admitted that the first oath of allegiance given to Abu Bakr was a falta.
A hasty slip.
An unconsidered, rushed decision.
Umar explicitly warned against anyone ever attempting to replicate such a chaotic process again.
The author seizes on this admission because it demolishes the central claim of the elected assembly from the inside out.
Yeah, if the succession was truly a divine command, or even the careful execution of the prophet's implicit wishes, it couldn't possibly be described by its architect as a hasty slip.
A divine appointment is not a scramble.
Umar concedes, by his own account, that the foundational act of their succession was not the considered execution of a divine mandate.
It was a rushed slip.
The caliph's own words, preserved in their own records, dismantled their claim to rightful authority.
The author has done nothing more than read their own history back to them.
When we step back and look at the entire scope of this argument, it is remarkable.
the author has taken us through the unbroken line of the prophets, demonstrating that from the angels onward, the earth always has a designated guide, and that guide never comes by human choice.
And he applied that exact principle to render a definitive verdict on history.
He measured the historical figures against the objective virtues of knowledge, holy struggle, and piety.
He found the chosen leaders wanting based on their own admissions, and he pointed to the one man who held all three virtues at their summit.
It all circles back to that terrifying
image of Noah's Ark.
History is a repeating test.
The people who drowned in the flood had the warning.
They saw the vessel clearly.
Their tragedy was trusting the solid ground beneath their own feet over the designated ship.
The earth is never left without a guide, and that guide comes by designation, never by election.
So we leave you with this to consider on your own.
When you look at the structure of your own decisions, where do you prefer your own judgment?
To a guide you've been plainly shown, and what would boarding that vessel cost you this week?